[Aplausos]
hablemos extraordinariamente
va a hablar extraordinariamente tengo
que tocar con lo que es mi historia
yo soy originaria de tlaxcala la escala
es un lugar paradisíaco uno de los
principales destinos turísticos la
repubblica
para los que no lo conocen evidentemente
esto no es la escala me encantaría que
se fuera de la escala hubiera tenido 16
años maravillosos la realidad es que es
la escala es el estado o era el estado
más pequeño de la república hasta que el
df se convirtió en la ciudad de mexico
entonces lo único que teníamos
importante en la republica nos han
quitado entonces las galas del segundo
estado más pequeño
y al ser el estado más pequeño también
la oferta que tienes de lo
extraordinario se reduce se reduce en un
montón de cuestiones que en ese momento
no te das cuenta que son extraordinarias
esta pequeñita soy yo hace varios años
para que no me calculen
vivía dentro de lo extraordinario y lo
extraordinario era tener una casa en el
árbol y que mi hermano uno de mis tres
hermanos me cobrarán entre cinco a diez
pesos para entrar a una casa que
nosotros habíamos construido juntos que
lo extraordinario tenía que ver con
salir mandar en la bici y recorrer
cuadras y cuadras en la bici sin que mi
mamá se preocupara de que algo me pueda
pasar
lo extraordinario tenía que ver con
mirar el canal 5 y escuchar lo que
pasaba en la gran ciudad y entonces
impresionarte porque nada me está
pasando en la scala
y entonces en este momento evidentemente
lo extraordinario era lo ordinario hasta
que un día mis papás deciden que nos
cambiamos de casa y entonces primer
evento extraordinario porque nos
cambiamos a una casa que está en obra
negra y entonces nos olvidamos de la luz
hago un paréntesis porque es la escala
es un estado pequeñito pero entonces
está pequeñito hay ciertos municipios
uno de sus municipios es apizaco yo
vivía en ese lugar y mis papás deciden
mudarse a apizaquito entonces imagínense
lo pequeñito que era es apizaquito
entonces llegamos a este piso quito
donde la casa no tenía luz entonces
alrededor de 23 meses vivimos con velas
un poco en el medioevo y los vecinos muy
amables decidieron compartirnos un poco
de luz pero teníamos un acuerdo si
nosotros perdemos en el microondas ellos
tenían que apagar todo si se nos ocurría
a prender la tele y el microondas bueno
los vecinos la pasaban bastante mal y
nosotros también porque fundíamos toda
la conexión eléctrica entonces van a
sofá lo extraordinario pero que me topo
con este nuevo extraordinario que para
llegar a esa casa teníamos que hacer un
recorrido donde pasábamos las vías del
tren mi mamá es maestra entonces algunos
de ustedes sabrán las implicaciones de
tener una mamá maestra y justo a la hora
que teníamos que entrar a la escuela el
tren pasado y a mi mamá como toda mamá
buena onda mamá comprensiva mamá que
quiere que sus hijos estudien decidí a
echarse carreritas con el tren y
entonces el tren venía por un lado mi
mamá por el otro los niños gritando mi
mamá histérica y todos los días se
quemaban la caja de velocidades cientos
nomás se bajaba en friega apagaba
cerraba el cofre y siempre nos llegó
temprano nunca falta la escuela nunca
ningún problema de puntualidad tomando
en cuenta que en apizaco todo está a
cinco minutos para bueno esto se volvió
parte también de lo ordinario
pero algo que recuerdo es que al llegar
a esta casa por primera vez me di cuenta
de lo que era la oscuridad absoluta de
lo que era mirar al cielo y ver las
miles y millones de estrellas que nos
ofrece el universo todos los días
escuchar a los grillos y él se volvió
parte de lo extraordinario
pero uno va creciendo no se puede seguir
haciendo muy linda crezco y gresko y me
topo con que mi realidad ordinaria tiene
que ver con ser una persona de pocos
amigos ser una persona que está
totalmente inmersa en la parte académica
en la parte del deporte que para muchos
podía hacer algo extraordinario porque
no tener amigos implica que tienes
tiempo para estudiar un montón entonces
mi promedio era alrededor de 98
pegándole al 10 me convertí en el tercer
lugar nacional de natación lo cual eso
se volvió extraordinario pero para mí
era lo ordinario para mí que era
extraordinario en una amiga no me
cancelará para ir a comer a la mera hora
para mí lo extraordinario era que alguna
de mis hermanos no respondiera a algo
que alguna mis hermanos no leyera mi
diario para mí lo extraordinario tenía
que ver con estas cosas que para el
resto de la gente el ordinario
entonces me quedé pensando en esta
situación
y digo que queremos decir cuando
hablamos de lo extraordinario a qué nos
referimos cuando escuchamos esta palabra
que se ha vuelto tan constante y resulta
que todo el mundo es extraordinario para
entonces todo el mundo es extraordinario
nadie es extraordinario y todos sabemos
el ordinario entonces llegamos como unas
cumple unas complejidades lingüísticas
entonces me tomé la molestia de buscar
la definición de extraordinario y la
definición de extraordinario dice que es
una palabra un adjetivo que le da una
cualidad al sujeto entonces lo
extraordinario tiene que ser algo de
fuera que le va a dar cualidad a otra
cosa
en este caso amigo
lo extraordinario es la escala el año
pasado
el año pasado inauguramos las primeras
escaleras eléctricas en todo el estado
gracias
[Aplausos]
pero no fue solo eso también se inauguró
el primer starbucks entonces todo el
todo el estado estábamos ahí las
descompusimos evidentemente bueno yo no
porque ellos están en mexico pero la
parte interesante es que lo
extraordinario de esto no eran las
escaleras eléctricas es que ya teníamos
un edificio de dos pisos entonces esto
forma parte de lo extraordinario
pero también tenemos cosas lindas
tenemos el santuario de las luciérnagas
cuando yo me cambio a esta nueva casa
tan extraordinariamente terrorífica y
novedosa en mi jardín había cientos de
bichos que les salía una luz de su
colita a los cuales mis perros
perseguían incansablemente
y ahora ya no están ahora todas están en
un santuario en las células de las
haciendas más lindas que tiene la
república y es cuando yo regreso un poco
a mi infancia y digo claro para mí lo
extraordinario cuando me cambié a esta
casa era prepararme un árbol hasta lo
más alto y ver como muy perro
amorosamente perseguía al guajolote la
vecina para mí lo extraordinario de
vivir en el cerro en el monte tenía que
ver con esperar 10 minutos para que las
vacas del vecino terminan de pasar y hoy
no tengo nada de eso pero entonces mi
ser extraordinario tenemos una cultura
impresionante tenemos una tradición muy
arraigada en las escalas invito a que
vayan y esta es una de las imágenes que
más me gustan tenemos a lo que se llaman
las camadas y las camadas es un grupo de
personas que se
que se disfrazan se disfrazan y se
llaman huevos son unos trajes sumamente
caros pero esto es algo que conmociona
todo el estado y todo el estado se
detiene para las cámaras entonces si
quieres viajar la escalada pues la te
tienes que esperar que termine la camada
que alrededor de un mes para que puedas
ir al pueblo entonces no sólo son las
cuestiones de mi historia ni las de mi
estado
sigo pensando entonces qué es lo que
tiene mi vida extraordinaria
que sería distinto ahora
y caigo en cuenta de que lo
extraordinario no es ni todo blanco ni
todo negro no es ni todo bueno ni todo
negativo hay unas escalas y hay una
serie de elementos que permiten que uno
tenga una vida extraordinaria y ahí es
cuando la chica de provincia decide dar
el gran paso agarrar su caja de bachoco
tomar el camión y venirse a la gran
ciudad eso casi les da un infarto a mis
papás porque imagínense la más chica de
tres hermanos el más grande me dio a 13
y de les digo me voy a la gran ciudad
ahí nos vemos y llego a la gran ciudad y
me encuentro con la realidad de lo
extraordinario y de que mi pueblo
realmente es ordinario y entonces me
empiezo a ver envuelta en el tránsito
vial me empiezo a ver vuelta en los
empujones en el metro en que no tengo ni
idea de cómo se maneja en que tengo que
aprender a manejar para poder trasladar
me a casa de mis papás empieza a dar
cuenta de lo mucho que extraño esta vida
provinciana que al final del día era
extraordinaria y entonces me doy cuenta
que dentro de estos cambios hay
elementos que hacen que tengamos
limitaciones y que tengamos
posibilidades cuáles son mis
limitaciones dentro de lo extraordinario
que no puedo ver a mi familia
frecuentemente que tengo que adaptarme
de otras familias
y cuáles son mis posibilidades mis
posibilidades se han convertido en
encontrar la parte obscura y la parte
brillante de lo extraordinario esta es
una parte obscura en una de las tantas
manifestaciones a las que he tenido
oportunidad de participar me pareció
bastante impactante que pusieran una
baja barrera de granaderos impidiendo
que gente común y corriente como yo
pudiéramos pasar a bellas artes para que
no va a analizar amos esto la
manifestación nada por los 43
estudiantes desaparecidos y para mí que
era la parte extraordinaria estar
haciendo un acto de protesta porque soy
maestra y para mí sería
extraordinariamente desgarrador que mis
alumnos desaparecieran y nadie me diera
respuesta
el 19 de septiembre de 2017 hubo un
sismo importante esto es una foto de mi
casa fue un evento extraordinario porque
porque no todos los días se me caía algo
en la casa afortunadamente y esto fue
impactante porque el efecto que tuvo fue
a grandes escalas no solo fue mi casa no
solo fue ese pedacito sino fue alrededor
de la república extraordinariamente
desgarrador pero ojo no todo es malo
también hay estas cuestiones
extraordinarias de lo lindo que te
puedan vender colores en una bolsita por
el simple placer de venderte colores que
puedas mirar como se oculte el sol y que
esta tarde se represente todo de lo que
tú puedes extrañar de lo ordinario que
se vuelve extraordinario
te puedas mirar los pies de la bebé de
una de tus amigas y veas lo
extraordinario que es ese pequeño pisito
que no ha tocado absolutamente nada y
puedes imaginar los grandes pasos que va
a dar no porque vaya a ser corredora
profesional pero tal vez porque su vida
la va a llevar a que tome decisiones que
le empujen como fue en mi caso
extraordinario es poder viajar poder
sentarte poder sentarte con un perro de
la calle sin más sin ningún pensamiento
y entonces es cuando llegó a esta
conclusión
qué hubiera pasado si yo no hubiera
nacido en la escala y yo digo
al demonio con él hubiera nos hemos
vuelto fanáticos de decir si yo hubiera
o no hubiera él hubiera es el pasado
inútil de lo que no quisieron hacer y no
pudieron hacer en ese momento sawyer la
escala y extraordinariamente hoy puedo
decir lo extraordinario depende de
ustedes lo extraordinario depende de esa
mente y lo que les posibilite ver cada
día una terrible lluvia que los permita
estar juntos en su casa risas con sus
amigos el olor de alguien despertar y
darte cuenta que hay otro día donde
tienes una oportunidad de ver estos
pequeños elementos que te hacen
extraordinario muchas gracias
[Aplausos]